what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python with open CV tutorial in
this tutorial what we're really talking
about is corner detection corner
detection can actually be used for quite
a few things mainly we're going to see
it in like three-dimensional recreation
you can see it in motion tracking and
also it gets used in a character
recognition fairly frequently so let's
go ahead and dive in we're going to be
using the following image feel free to
use this image or create your own as
usual the image for this tutorial is
available at Python programming net for
this tutorial you can also click the
link in the description for the specific
tutorial so that's the image we're going
to use an ideally we're going to try
find all of the corners now that said it
might be kind of hard to tell in this
picture I can tell actually you should
be able to tell that little the thing on
the on the left that I drew there drew
it in Microsoft Paint and as you can see
those the slanted lines have quite a bit
of aliasing issues going on or so so
what we're going to be doing is
detecting corners and what it's going to
do is find all the corners so with all
that jaggedy edges going on there a lot
of corners are probably going to be
detected if you let them be detected so
anyway and rightly so those are corners
so keep that in mind so now what we're
going to do is you'll need CV 2 and
numpy imported and then what we're going
to go ahead and do is image and that
image that we're just looking at I've
got it saved so CV to Emory to bringing
the image that an image name that I
called it was open CV - corner -
detection - sample jpg and then we're
going to gray it out we're going to say
see the to convert color image CV to
color
underscore BG R to gray then finally
again gray now is going to equal NP
float32 we're just converting this to a
float32
of correct
and that's mostly just out of satisfy
the algorithm that we're going to use to
actually find the corners so now corners
is equal to cv two good features to
track and then against gray we're going
to find up to a hundred of them zero
point zero one here and basically that's
quality and then finally the minimum
distance between corners so when you're
running this algorithm it's on what how
many are we willing to you know find up
to image quality and then the minimum
yeah minimum distance between every time
it finds a corner so in the case of like
slanty lines like we've got if you put
that number high enough it's not going
to catch those you know alias slides as
often anyway it'll so find them it'll
just make them few and far between so
it's corners and then finally we're
going to commit convert that to numpy
dot int zero of corners at any point
when we use numpy and we do these
conversions
feel free to print out the results if
you're not sure what it's going to look
like printed out generally it's just
data type conversions I wouldn't spend
too much time worrying about these
conversions it could just as easily be
happening in the back end and you really
wouldn't have known these even existed
it just so happens that to work with CV
we got to do this stuff so anyway now
we're going to go ahead and do is we're
going to say for corner in corners what
do we want to do x y equals corner
rattle and then we're going to create a
circle now so CV to die is circle and
we're going to do this circle at on the
image in the location of X Y for that
the center the radius will be three
color 285 and then negative one fill
that bad boy in finally C V to M show
will show the corners
on the image and I think that's good
let's run that okay sure enough we find
pretty much all the corners possible I
don't really see any other corners
besides maybe in the inside of that e
that would have been nice and the bottom
of that Y should have been a corner but
we probably ran out of corners so for
example if we did 200 we might actually
get all those filled in well we did get
down on the Y we did not get on the
inside
E I'm guessing it's this this aliasing
over here that's really causing us
trouble let's accept up to 20,000
corners nope still don't get it in there
so maybe that's not it's just not a
corner y'all it doesn't exist but let's
say detracts ten corners right is just
going to find ten corner so Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam and then some over here okay so
you just want to make sure you're going
to let as many corners show up as
possible it doesn't appear to actually
give like weights to any of the corners
like obviously the corners of the
squares should be like immediately
picked but not necessarily are they
actually picked so anyway so that's core
detection and again that would be used
you can use corner detection to track
objects motions or with three rendering
like sometimes you want to take a
picture of something and then maybe 3d
print that something if you can detect
the corners and you can draw lines
between the corners you can help to kind
of render that object in 3d so that's
corner detection and the other thing
that people use it for is actually
character recognition if you detect the
corners of characters and then draw
lines between those corners a lot of
times the character actually comes to
life so so it's using character
recognition as well especially if
they're fat characters like we've got
going on here if you kind of connected
all these these are maybe too fat but if
you connected all these dots you would
actually kind of see like oh yeah those
are differently there's a shape going on
there the e would be kind of hard but
anyway
in the next tutorial we're going to be
talking about is actually feature
matching between images so so far as far
as like using object recognition of any
type we've done template recognition
we're going to be talking about the next
tutorial is a little bit more advanced
so templates going to match almost
identically based on template whereas
what we're about to do is feature
matching which doesn't necessarily it
may not be as accurate but it's going to
be a lot more nimble than template
matching was so anyways that's what you
guys have to look forward to if you have
any questions comments concerns whatever
on this tutorial feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the support
subscriptions and until next time